done Wizards of Waverly Place you've
done pretty little liars you've done
faking it
do you remember your very first audition
out here what my first audition was with
Selena
what was it yeah runaway star Gregg
Sulkin telling et about landing his
first ever audition in the u.s. it was
with Selena Gomez for Wizards of Waverly
Place
I love it twenty-five-year-old braises
former co-star and is down for a Wizards
reunion speaking of Selena how proud are
you of her and where she's coming you
know it's like Disney Channel star and
then there's like worldwide pop stars
yeah she's yeah I mean she's she's
transitioned into becoming
be one of the biggest superstars in the
world who can sell out arenas so I'm
happy it's happened to a nice person
because you know I know a lot of people
in this industry who seem a certain way
and maybe on but I think with her I
think she is has always been really
lovely has always been very determined
hard-working and you know is she if you
look type in like Selena Gomez scandal
on on Google you'll never find one I
know that last year she went to David
Henry's wedding and there was maybe like
a joke about is there gonna be a Wizards
reunion ever
I was shooting and I couldn't go to
David's wedding I was so angry because
David's like my best best best friend um
I think maybe in like 10 15 years maybe
okay that show gave me my start and so
I'll always be grateful and I'd always
want to do when the time is right a
reunion for sure before that happens
greg has a suggestion for the network
that helped launch his career I do
believe that Disney Channel should have
a some sort of like every week they
should have a therapy sessions the wrong
word because I you know it sounds like
extreme but like a conversation meeting
where like these kids including myself
when they're 17 18
even 14 that is hard to remain
level-headed so I do believe that there
should be like once a week on any young
network there should be somebody to come
in it comes in and talks to these young
actors about just their life and like
hearing like their teenage thoughts
because I think it's hard when you're
being told and becoming up and you don't
realize it you're becoming like a
multi-million dollar business right and
I think it's tough one thing I want to
do with my voice so to speak is to make
sure that younger actors don't end up
going down the path of some actors that
we've seen throughout the years I'm
surprised that they don't always do okay
very surprised that's an amazing point
and I think that is so important and we
have seen you know some tragic stories
along the way and you know what would
have a conversation with like peers and
some adults done to help that I mean I
think that's a great idea for sure like
even if it's a record record labels or
such as in the acting industry by
Nickelodeon Disney like there's you know
it's toffee people ways judge it's very
easy to judge a celebrity so to speak on
like how they're behaving or how they're
not behaving or they're doing this wrong
or they're doing that they're taking you
put yourself into their shoes and their
mind but it's not easy
you